today we're talking about apigee x
underwater cables
and cloud dns peering welcome to this
week in cloud
where we serve you the lowest latency
news
apis are the backbone of digital
transformation
and to help organizations navigate
today's very challenging landscape
we're announcing apogee x a major
release
of our api management platform apigee x
seamlessly weaves together google
cloud's expertise in ai
security and networking to help
enterprises
efficiently manage the assets on which
digital transformation initiatives
are built we're thrilled to say bonjour
to the do not submarine cable system
named after henry dunot which has been
deployed
and tested and is now ready for service
duno features a new design and will
deliver
record-breaking capacity of 250
terabytes per second
across the large and vast ocean this is
enough to transmit
the entire digitized library of congress
three times
every second we're committed to building
an excellent network with
well-provisioned direct paths between
our cloud and
our customers take a look at this blog
for more info
sometimes application teams want to
manage their own dns records
there's a solution to support
fine-grained iim
policies using cloud dns peering
in this article we explore how to use it
to give your application teams autonomy
over their dns records while ensuring
that the central networking team
maintains granular control over the
entire environment
machine learning or ml can help you
solve
hard business problems in new ways but
getting started can feel overwhelming
we're fortunate to have some great
leaders in google cloud ai who have
decades of experience
and want to share some advice for
getting started
from their learnings check out the blog
for some videos from our experts
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us thank you
for being here we'll see you
in the cloud cheers